how do you how do you guys manage how'd
you manage the stress I mean Craig don't
know probably just being able to go lock
yourself away in a separate room albeit
working but a slight distraction from
what you're doing constantly but what is
it any mind is getting other people
watching this as well maybe in a similar
situation maybe in a completely
different situation but for you guys is
there a way that you are able to manage
this stress is there is there some tips
that you might be able to give to other
people there's lots of things that then
I had this conversation with Colin
yesterday and I'm terrible for not
listening to my own advice because if I
was within the family tree right now I'd
be saying you know read a book go run in
and have a bath this calm apps
hemisphere there's all sorts of apps but
I don't listen to my own advice for me
and look if I can't go out I can't go
for a walk or run because I'm shielding
with safety and so just being able to go
in the garden and as I mentioned before
saving save SAS that you say for me it's
actually making sure I'm enjoying the
family time but I need to remind myself
as much as I'm getting stressed and
getting frustrated with you know trying
to get the communication right trying to
speak to professionals trying to get the
TV equipment I have to remind myself to
step away if I step away and then making
sure I'm enjoying that quality time with
family everything just seems to you know
everything goes back and I just like
okay I'm alright now you know we might
be throwing paint around in the garden
we might be baking bread whatever as we
do in just enjoying that quality family
time you see it's quite an easy way to
them to get the stresses and the Warrens
of what's going on out there at the
moment I'm submit we've been really
amazed during this story during this
time where we're getting literally daily
text messages and photographs of the
families do I share in their appearances
are they a lot there's a lot of fun
going on under time and every is worried
about there's also a lot of fun and a
lot of family time going on in those
houses and it is really lovely to see I
think this is great we just don't know
hopefully it's not going to be too much
longer but we just don't know and you
know it's trap
fantastic sit there smiling and the
experience there's going to be something
you have to deal with and there's no way
that you can run away from your point
even destruction yourself in a different
room but as long as you guys I think you
picked ahead of making you know
remembering to laugh and have fun one of
the things we've started to do with
safety and I don't know what I'm going
to live to regret it but she really
loves me regional reason Rachel you'll
know from every time she's been in I see
she wants me to read her story so we
read the story but when we have to do
the really ridiculous so we've been
recording them and showing them with a
friend and we're going to be recording
them and sharing them with well-child so
well television quite a bit with the
world child TV they when so you never
know I could send it your way aren't you
you could have a little story
you're a shining example of just being a
super parent and and spinning so many
plates and juggling so many balls at the
same time it's amazing it really is
amazing and to see you smiling and you
know either grinning and baring it or
genuinely just like this is this is like
certain extenders there's not much that
you can do about it except where is the
where is like to be in the time let's
focus on mind and keep the morale up
because it's all about morale if you're
always up if you're waking up in the
morning going right new day they've got
my whole family here what are we gonna
do of course there's that fear of what
might happen but there's so much that's
out of our control all of a sudden we
now realize how small we are
[Music]